they're billions of queries every month
on health
we've gotta find information on the
internet but it's so much of it and
we're getting lost it's not about really
Who I am it's just like a lot of
information that is very confusing and I
don't know who wrote this information
it's very hard to establish trust so the
beautiful thing about health topics that
it's democratizing high quality doctor
created health information how to gives
you access to the best health
information but also the best doctors in
real time immediate access which is
revolutionary the advice and guidance of
now over fifty thousand doctors with
literally millions of answers is
available to anyone anywhere around the
globe at anytime for free I'm a builder
I'm an inventor I've always thought of
myself as someone who wants to do good
in the world who wants to make a
difference but all sorts care health
care is one of the last frontiers that
were not yet revolutionized by
information technology in the United
States we spend about five hundred
billion dollars on the doctor patient
visit alone about 25 percent are
informational that's me reimbursing you
for a time in person to talk to a doctor
in a very expensive way that is
replaceable by a much cheaper and more
efficient interaction done health of
doctors and patients are using mobile
devices web interfaces to come and
interact with one another in a new land
that is actually in the cloud and this
new land is really promising because
it's all digital and it's immediate and
and for us from day one we decided that
we
will redefine the way people find the
best health information in ways that
we're just not possible before whenever
you have a brand-new chat you kind of
freak out if anything happens with our
son he had a rash after we go through
all these forums we're talking about
different colors of rashes and looking
at images of awful rashes that our son
might have it was oh it almost terrified
us and somewhere down the line on the
Internet we found healthTap we were just
to ask a question and got a response
back within 10 20 minutes it was there
and and doctor mentioned that it may be
the laundry detergent that we were using
and they were absolutely right the key
is it was reliable and it helped us out
financially one of the things I hear
from patients all the time is do I need
to go to the emergency room directly to
a specialist or as a primary care doctor
the right person to see and in many ways
on health tap patients are being triaged
they're being guided to the right place
and over time that will increase the
efficiency and decrease the costs of
health care I became a doctor because I
wanted to help people and with health
tap I was investing a little bit of time
answering a question in short I helped
that one person who asked the question
but over time that answer is reaching
millions of people
it's really great to receive this
thank-you note saying thank you so much
for taking that time the reward is
really not the money the reward seems to
be having that opportunity to help and
feeling like we can help fast
with something that we already know what
health of does it captures this very
very important knowledge to actually
bring you these answers when you need
them most
and we created very sophisticated
technology to know which doctor is most
likely to answer right now only where
they have deep expertise and even more
so only the things they're passionate
about answering were codified capturing
making searchable classifying health
answers for generations to come as a
service to society our role is really to
invent the right interfaces to make it
very accessible very easy to use and we
take our trade to the next level but
caring artisans create not just a
product or a service they create art
there is a lot of feedback that we get
and we do our best to take it all into
consideration to respond to every
incoming message personally within the
first hour on one hand it's this
adventure of innovation things that
haven't been created yet and then on the
other hand it's creating a product that
people are depending on their life could
be depending on I love
machine learning I love predictive
morning and I'll be big data but it's
not just the use of cool technologies it
is that the fact that we taking this
cutting-edge technology and applying
them to practical problems and saving
lives every day that's what inspires me
that's what inspires everyone
it's fascinating how when you you really
want to take care of something the
universe gives you what you need and I
just found this app somewhere and so I
just said you know I've had these red
spots in my nose
they've been there for over two years
now and I got our response pretty quick
we can't help you we can't give you much
until someone you know looks at it and
touches it nobody can really help you
until you go to a doctor it was nothing
that I expected she said actually you
have spots on your face that are cancer
honestly it was pretty shocking to me I
was pretty floored milk tap did saved my
life you know I do I feel that way we're
an amazing juncture in time our platform
will enable doctors to deliver care
directly to people online electronically
in a much more convenient and efficient
way than has ever been possible before
the mobile health revolution is is
amazing and it's just starting I think
the fact that everyone around the world
will have a mobile device in the next
few years in many places way before they
have running water or even electricity
is something that is mine why because
people will have access for the first
time to the best medical knowledge and
it's very exciting I feel like we have
the opportunity together to change the
world to change healthcare to
dramatically impact the way healthcare
is provided and the beautiful thing
about what we're doing versus a static
website is it have to be refreshing
itself all the time every minute every
hour all of that feeds into my own brain
as a doctor to think about some other
things that I would not have found on a
textbook that I may not have even
learned from my experience or practice
but that will raise my awareness when
all doctors are connected and they're
all connected to people everywhere
our ability to accelerate the treatments
that actually work and to get rid of the
things that actually don't work is
unbelievable we're building a company
that will be around forever creating
this repository is something that is
valuable today but will be valuable in
500 years from now easily how tough is
one of these rare products and services
that can actually serve a hundred
percent of people and my dream is to do
a concierge medicine for everyone that
this health opposed a health companion
will be available for you to solve any
health problem that you have for you or
for your loved ones and that's my dream
and then they will changes for the
better
this time on this side of the auditorium
I you know love being back on campus I
see some great familiar faces and it's
amazing to be back and you know today I
thought about what what would have been
most valuable to me you know if I sat in
your seats and then I said to myself why
would I need to think about it I just
need to go back you know and think about
it when I sat and watched ETL talks when
I was in your seat and that was not too
long ago
well I'm carrying our tenth year reunion
in a couple of weeks from now so maybe
it fast faster then then I thought it
would so enjoy your time here enjoy
every minute of it
because when you go to the real world
and you do what you wanna do you're
gonna take a lot of the lessons that you
learned here when you're sitting in
these seats and make them happen in the
real world and I thought to myself when
I was in your seat what are the things
that I wanted to learn what would have
been most valuable to me and the talk
today I'll try to share with you some of
these inside that I've learned over the
years and hopefully that would be
valuable to you in your lives when you
graduate from here and go and change the
world for the better a lot of you will
in a very very profound way so let me
start by you know tying it back to the
videos with the tea just so and and
start with like something that will has
been very very important for me from the
time that I was here at Stanford
throughout the past ten years of my
journey and it was all about the mission
right if you look at the story of
healthTap the company that I founded we
started about four and a half years ago
it's all started with a very important
mission a mission to measurably prolong
the life expectancy of humankind and
help everyone around the world feel good
by giving them access to the best health
information and doctors anytime anywhere
ding mission-driven
is awesome doesn't matter what you do
you know when you wake up in the morning
and you know that you do some
thing that is meaningful it gives you
amazing amount of energy and if you
decide to be an entrepreneur how many
people around the room want to be an
entrepreneur at one point in their
career or participated aweso I'm back
home that's great
and so if you want to be an entrepreneur
you're going to take on yourself
journeys that would be challenging
because if it was easy to do the thing
that you want to do probably many other
people are already doing it it's
probably solved and there's not much to
do there so you're gonna take on
yourself a challenge a really hard and
important challenge and when you do that
and you do it day after day after day
you're never really gonna wake up some
mornings and ask yourself why am I doing
this right this is really challenging
right I wanted to go from here to here I
had this like great idea it was
fantastic I told it to some people it
was amazing I thought it's gonna just
take you know a few weeks or a few
months and it's just gonna work exactly
there I wanted to work but you know then
you go there and things are not working
exactly the way you wanted them to work
and it happens again and again and again
and again you know one thing that is
really difficult to all the most
accessible to preneur that I met in my
career was they would tell you that they
got way more nose than the asses at any
given point in that you got nose when
you go in and try to raise money you get
nose when you try to hire the best
people you get nose when you try to
partner with like these big partners but
your idea is so great why would everyone
invest in me why wouldn't anyone partner
with it
anyone would join you anyone it's like
it's just such an amazing idea it will
change the world like this but then you
start doing it and you realize that you
know they are the hurdles there and when
they happen the one thing that never
gets old is a mission it's really
believing in what you do and wanted to
accomplish something that is actually
very very meaningful very meaningful to
you but even better very very meaningful
for the world
because when you do something that
matters to a lot of people and you know
that what you will do will actually make
a huge impact in the world it will keep
you going every single day and it never
gets old
when you are there to measurably prolong
the life
humankind and you believe that you will
do it eventually even when it's hard you
just know that it's gonna be hard it's
okay you just acknowledge it and the
most successful people I met in my life
where they wanted understood and
acknowledged the the journey and
embraced it when I hire people I tell
them that we are here to conquer Everest
and it's very it's you know it's great
to say right like I mean how cool is
that I mean we're you know we're
conquering this amazing challenge and
we're gonna make it happen and it's you
know so romantic and everything and and
you know what people tend to forget when
they say okay I'm gonna go climb Everest
is that you know when you get to the
middle of the mountain it can be it
becomes kind of cold and kind of steep
and kind of slippery right I mean it's
like it you know it's Everest and and
when I talk with people and I explain to
them that I tell them that what I'm
looking for is not for people that will
endure the journey I'm looking for
people that will enjoy the journey that
love the challenges that embrace the
challenges that have a mission that they
know that they want to get to the summit
right because we want to get there we
want to make it happen but most
importantly enjoy the journey to getting
there so if you have a mission it will
keep you going on the way to the summit
but if you understand the journey you
will enjoy the journey particularly
particularly and that's the second thing
that I want to talk about if you're
surrounded by the right people so have a
mission pick yourself a mission and then
surround yourself with the right people
nobody goes to climb Everest themselves
well I mean most people don't I think
you shouldn't if you think about it
right take a team with you take the
right kind of people but not only the
people that share the same vision and
mission that you have because it's
important right it's important to figure
out that they really want to conquer the
same summit that you want to conquer
right did they have a similar vision and
it what you have and it's important for
you to actually talk talked a lot with
them about it because you know sometimes
it's like you know they're kind of the
cursory mission that you have or
something that you where you want to get
well the summit is there and everyone's
like yeah we'll get to the summit but
then we start talking about it maybe
some people think about this part of the
summit or that part or you know how to
get there etcetera etcetera it's
important that you have really the same
mission the same vision but even more
importantly so it's extremely important
that you get along with them well beyond
the fact that you live only once right I
think at least I - yeah well it's
important to enjoy the journey as you go
there and you only enjoyed the journey
if you surround yourself with people
that you're having fun with when I sat
in your seats not so many years ago I
want to convince myself I I listen to
Vinod Khosla
who's an entrepreneur and now an
investor and and you know when he talked
about really how to bring the right
people around you someone in the
audience asked him a question so how do
you how do you choose the right people
how do you choose the people to bring
with you to the journey and the way he
answered it was I tried to bring with me
the people that I wouldn't mind getting
in trouble with which was sort of an
interesting insight right so not only
people to enjoy partying with which is
important you want to have fun with
people because when you go on a journey
you really want to enjoy the way but
you're gonna conquer challenges together
you're gonna tackle things that were
you've never tackled before and certain
people behave in a certain way and when
things are going really well
when they party and everything's fine
right then you're you know you're
enjoying yourself and then when the
challenges happen right
you know maybe they behave a little bit
differently and you mean to make sure
that you're compatible with these people
when things go great and you celebrate
and and everything is awesome and that's
important because you wanna have fun all
the time or most of the time but you
also want to make sure that the people
that you're with are compatible with you
when things are not going that great
right and how do you check that I mean
you can you can do stuff with people you
know go out with them you know go in
nature you know when I interview people
when I talk with people you know I don't
just do particularly people in important
positions in the company I
just sit down in an offices do the cuff
front of the interview I'll take them up
let's go for a hike
all right let's let's change the
environment a little bit you know some
people are really great in interviewing
I'm sure that nobody here ever prepares
interviews because you know Stanford but
well so elsewhere around the world
people prepare interviews so some people
become really really good in
interviewing right and they try to
convince you that this is the bet they
are the best in the world and they're
the best match which is great I mean I
think all of us are trying to prove that
what we're doing is great and good but
if you want to figure out if the fit is
great take them out of the comfort zone
take them out of the office and start
spending some time with them the best
thing in my mind is spending some time
with them in nature right go for a hike
you know go outside talk walk write have
a conversation try to talk about
scenarios and don't just ask questions
at our interview questions right try to
talk about scenarios you know tell me
about a time that you do this and that
and let's have a conversation about how
did it unpack what do you think about
that and that when you did that not just
give me a set of actions of what you did
but hey try to unpack for me how you
think a little bit right particularly if
you're thinking about co-founders of
people that you are in the core team
that you want to spend many many years
with you want to take the time you want
to surround yourself with a bunch of
people that you will enjoy working with
but we can also conquer challenges with
especially if you have a very important
very lofty mission that you want to
accomplish because that's not going to
happen in like two months it's not going
to happen in two years either right
there's a long journey that you're going
to go with together and to make sure
that you enjoy it and make sure that you
actually conquer it together make sure
that it's a good fit right so a lot of
you will spend a lot more time with your
co-founders or with people in your core
team then you spend with your spouse's
right so so think about it right it's an
important decision and it's an important
decision to keep on an ongoing basis so
we have you know we have a hairy and
audacious you have a mission that is
very important we have the people around
us right and we need to make sure that
with months we have the mission and we
have the people around us we need to
make sure that we continue talking about
the
and make sure that all of us are sharing
it together and that's an extremely
important point it's not that just at
the very beginning of the company you
defined yourself what is the you know
the mission in this vision of the
company but how you keep it going
all the time and keep it fresh and make
it something that is meaningful but haft
up when we start at the beginning before
we wrote the first line of code and
actually in fact before we wrote the
first sketch on a napkin or any you know
balsamic you know sketch on an iPad we
actually spend of almost two weeks
defining a vision and credo for the
company and writing to ourselves in
detail what are the values that are very
very important for us what are the
things that we stand by for Valentino V
stands for what are the things that are
important for us to make what we want to
make happen and we thought about these
values and you know this tells this
whole paradigm there that says all you
need to have maybe like six to eight or
well you know like they're different
people think about it differently or
like how many values you need to have
and reset yourself let's just outline
all of the values that we believe in and
then try to figure out which are they
wanted the most important for us and you
know when I put the list that it was
longer than the typical six eight and
whatever the number is we started
eliminating a few of them and putting
some of them together but ended up with
a list that were very very passionate
about when we did it with the entire
team was a small team back then but we
did it with the entire team together and
that was very very cool process but that
was just one point in time and then we
start writing code or start doing design
we start doing product and iterations
what was very important for us from that
point on was to make sure that this
remains fresh the division in the credo
and these values are things that we
actually uphold that we actually live by
so how do you do it because you're so
busy you work around the clock you don't
sleep at night you don't have enough
people to do what you need to do and you
need to do it quickly because you have
very little resources and you could
prove a lot so who has time for values
and vision and I mean like seriously I
mean come on give me a break
and that's the most important thing this
is the glue that keeps it all together
if you lose the mission or you lose the
values and and the kind of people if you
want a strong
yourself but you're not going to
accomplish what you're trying to
accomplish so the way we tackle this one
was if we have a team meeting every week
and we have a town hall meeting every
weekend and then we come all of us come
together and every team meeting we
actually choose one of the values in our
vision and credo and have a discussion
about keep it fresh talk about right do
people still believe in it do people
think it's still applicable maybe we
need to change certain things right so
people talk about the value just one
value every every week we choose one
value and talk about we decided to name
the conference rooms in our office with
the values right so we don't just put a
plaque on the wall that never nobody let
ever look that right it's a term company
did you see that all this this plaque
that nobody ever looks at then it has
all the values and whatever we actually
know people talk about conference room
let's meet at you know passion and
positive energy sense of adventure data
and analysis right these are the names
of the rooms in our office so they meet
there right and teamwork and
collaboration is a big room in our
office right and they talk about it so
it becomes part of the routine of how
we're thinking about the company and we
live by it and then we have a retreat
every single year we have a yearly
retreat that we take the entire company
together and the retreat starts with the
question why why are we here why are we
doing what we're doing so the same thing
that we started the company every yearly
retreat starts with the question of why
and going back to the vision and credo
and allowing anyone and everyone in the
company to say hey we think that this
value is just not applicable anymore
or hey we want to add something here or
I'm not sure that we're living by this
is this still something that belongs in
a company that has now you know 70
people rather than a company that had
five at the beginning or when we want to
go to 200 and 300 will that still be
applicable do you have too many do we
don't have enough the discussion goes on
and on and it's really important so
keeping the values not just writing them
is something that will help you keep it
all together so mission and vision
and the people right and keep the
discussion going on all the time about
what matters to you makes the journey
much better and makes the whole thing
matter every single day the third thing
that I want to talk about is hairy and
audacious goals right so I think that
each and every one of you if you came
here to this school and each and every
one of you all over the globe that takes
the time to watch this talk has some
hairy audacious goal in mind of what
they want to accomplish in life right
you you are ready to put more energy
you're ready to put more soul and heart
into doing something that is meaningful
remember we have a vision we have a
mission we're surrounded by great people
but how big the vision is right is the
bit is the vision as big as oh let's
make a hundred million dollars or a
billion dollars is that the vision is
that really hairy audacious goal maybe I
mean you know there are some professions
that it's all about making money in it
fine but is there something more to life
than that is there something more to
what you want to accomplish in life then
that and how big the thing is and how do
you measure how big it is so choosing a
vision choosing a mission that is very
very meaningful to you it's something
that is very important and I can tell
you after ten years of doing this you
know it's been ten years since I was
sitting in your seat
that choosing something that is really
big is super motivating for a very very
long period of time and it's possible to
do my philosophy has always been if it's
humanly possible to do if I put my mind
into it
I'll bring the right people with me
together we will be able to do it and
each and every one of you that sits in
this room actually can so when you
choose what you want to do in life when
you think about you know what you want
to do with yourself whether it's an
entrepreneur or if you want to work for
a company that does certain things I
really highly recommend to you to think
about a goal and a mission that is very
very lofty that is actually going to
help a lot of people do something that
is very very meaningful
in their lives I chose health and
well-being I think health is something
that underlies all of our life it's a
mutant it's something that empowers us
to do everything else it touches a
hundred percent of people I can't tell
you how motivating it is to go to work
every day or to meet people now all over
the world and around the country and
tell them what I'm doing it doesn't
matter if it's in a cocktail party or
when I mean family members or when I go
to a meeting or I just travel and people
ask me what I do I'm very very proud of
what I'm doing because I can say that
I'm saving lives every day we get
millions and millions of thank-you notes
every term from people all over the
world thanking our doctors we have more
than 68,000 doctors in our network today
and we're getting notes from people
every single day thanking our doctors
for the impact and we got millions of
them and among the more than 20,000
people send notes for us thanking us for
saving their life and that's amazing I
mean I cannot tell you I mean like every
single day every single day I still go
back to my notes and when I need a
moment to just feel good myself I just
read these notes and you will be
surprised how this never gets old
it never gets all to read the notes from
someone to say thank you for saving my
life and here's how you saved my life my
husband's life my child's life it never
gets old if you look at the hierarchy of
needs and we're you know Maslow's
hierarchy of needs which I'm sure that
all of you encountered around your time
here at school you'll see that at the
top of the pyramid
there's self-actualization and helping
others feels better than anything else
sure you need to do the basics you know
everyone needs to eat and everyone needs
to have the basics but at the end of the
day if you find yourself a mission and a
vision of doing something that is very
very meaningful in my case it was like
you know helping people improve their
health and well-being
saving lives every day it does not get
old ever and if you can combine the two
together and create a livelihood around
something that actually makes such a big
impact on humanity it will keep you
extremely motivated throughout your
entire journey and that's a lot of fun
so we had mission
vision we had people that's very
important now we have a very very hairy
audacious goal that we want to
accomplish in life and and it's very
important to us to think about you know
how can we you know bring it to let's
let's land it for a second how do you
make it happen so what's the most
important thing now that we have the
vision the mission the people the big
goal now we need to make it happen so
what kind of advice yeah someone said it
here what kind of advice can I give you
about that and then I'm going to go back
to the product right at the end of the
day you know maybe you know as a product
guy you know sometimes for a hammer the
entire world looks like a nail a little
bit but it's okay
right so I think it's all about the
products I think it's all about the
people that you're serving if you decide
to change the world in a certain way and
just have a big strategy you know we
love thinking strategy without thinking
big things without thinking about oh if
we do this and how it impacts that and
the markets and the you know like you
know we can think big you know we learn
Afghans were to think big right so think
strategy and I will tell you think about
the use case boil it down to the need
think about what they're in if you look
at the big picture of what we're trying
to solve trying to boil it down to the
essence what really matters where is the
need and where it lies and once you
understand the need and it's very very
granular how can you build from this
particular need to the big thing that
you want to build when I started helped
up at the beginning and I wanted to
change healthcare I really wanted to
change healthcare I thought that
healthcare is broken I thought that
there's so much to solve in it like it's
impossible if you look at how people
manage their health if you look at
healthcare cost I mean there's a huge
global challenge to solve but you know
we had five people and we were you know
on university I when you try to think in
a tiny little office of you know how can
we change the world and how can we
change healthcare as a product guy I had
to think about the basics the most
granular thing and the way I did it was
very very simple I went all the way back
to caveman time and this is
I think about the product at the
beginning it's been very very good for
me to add my entire career to really
take the experience all the way back to
caveman time because if you think about
it for a second any successful and
extremely useful digital experience that
you are using extensively in your life
if you boil it down to the essence
it was extremely similar to the wasting
were done in cavemen time if you boil it
out by the way I I'm a huge believer
that as human beings we have not changed
a lot since then I'm very serious about
think about at the essence right of what
really matters and particularly if you
want to build something that scales that
needs to be applicable to all people you
need to go to the granular essence of it
you need to understand what are the
underlying human factors that will
impact everyone think how simple and
granular they need to be so I went back
all the way to caveman time and asked
myself how was healthcare practice in
caveman time it's a good question right
so there was you know there's a person
that didn't feel well they had something
in their hand maybe and they went to a
healer right which was there you know
how humanity was passing the health
knowledge from generation to generation
so did a wise people that had the health
knowledge and there were the healers and
a person went to the healer and told
them you know I have a pain in my hand
it's been going on for you know four or
five days and it's kind of like blue now
what should I do
and the healer gave them a spell and a
portion and send them back home and 33%
of the time they felt better because of
the placebo effect and it worked right
and but you know interestingly enough
when you think about it health care
hasn't changed much since there we still
the health care experience is exactly
the same but you're not feeling well you
go to waiting or to a doctor right and
you tell them you know this is what's
going on and they give you maybe you
know there's more than a portion in a
spell but you know maybe there's a
little bit more science there right but
they experience the health care
experience remain the same
so I said to myself okay so watch the
granular experience where's the question
you have a doctor you have a healer you
have a doctor on the one hand and you
have a patient or a person on the other
hand and the first interaction is
question-and-answer so we took that put
it in digital channels we started with
pregnant women and moms with
pediatricians and obstetricians
and magic everyone understood it very
quickly it was very easy to communicate
to the moms and the pregnant women it
was very easy to communicate to the
doctors that you know they're going to
do exactly what they always did they're
just going to do it using mobile devices
or web interfaces and everyone's like oh
great now I can instead of going reading
on a website some articles I can go and
ask doctors questions that's awesome I
understand the value proposition doctor
understood it really well because the
answer questions all day long now they
did it just in digital channel that's
how it all started with a handful of
pediatricians and obstetrician and a
bunch of pregnant women in March fast
forward you know 68,000 physicians more
than 4,000 cities and towns across the
country doctors in 137 specialties today
impacting hundreds of millions of people
all over the world it's really amazing
and you know why I always like saying
that if I got a dime for every person
that told me the doctors will never
answer people's questions for free
online I would never need to raise money
for this company ever and 2.8 billion
doctors answers later that we serve to
people and it's still happening every
second now I can tell you that you know
we had something amazing that happened
there because we started with something
extremely simple something extremely
granular so we started with these
questions and answers that was very easy
to do and today doctors are answering
questions you can access doctors from
any mobile device or web connection and
by the way now from wearables as well
right we just announced our first app on
the Apple watch
so it was the first ever have healthcare
app on the Apple watch you can push a
button on the watch swipe the phone and
you see a doctor here in second all
right so that's the generation that what
you can do today right you have a button
on the watch and see a doctor here in
seconds but
that's charted with questions and
answers doctors are answering questions
on health dub they're creating tips
they're curating news all over the web
they're raiding apps health app there
more than 100,000 health apps in the App
Store so doctors are helping by reading
them and as of lately a few weeks ago
doctors started reading medications so
you can go to health talk to them
because we have such a big army of peace
of doctors that are available to
interact with patients but they're also
available to interact with one another
and what they started doing is reading
medications right so you can come to
health tap and just let you go on Amazon
or on Yelp you can actually go to a
condition page and see all the
medications that are used to treat this
condition and you can actually see how
they array out derated against each
other for efficacy how effective they
are one to five stars just like you
would do with like any product or
service that you used to anywhere else
and that was not possible before
and someone calculated to us what would
and we have more than five thousand
medication indication pairs now on
health top right and if you think about
it clinical studies for drugs right when
they're approved are done as a drug
versus placebo one drug versus possible
very rarely when they're compared to one
another why because it's very very
expensive to run the experiment that we
are running right now but with thousands
of drugs right in thousands of
indications would cost billions of
dollars even if you did it in one point
in time and we're doing it on an ongoing
basis in just one engagement but the
doctors are doing right now and it's
amazing cause for the first time ever
you can actually compare efficacy of
drugs for particular indication because
we have 68,000 doctors and they're
engaged but it all started with a very
simple interaction questions and answers
easy to explain to the user very easy to
explain to the doctor
and start bringing more and more doctors
start bringing more and more users and
now we can create magic now we can
actually give you the ability to see
what doctors are thinking about certain
things we can give you immediate access
to doctors that I just explained that we
basically give you access on text on
video on voice to doctors 24/7 from any
mobile device or personal computer and
now from wearables as well
and that's pretty amazing but we started
very simply and very granularly so when
you think about what you want to start
when you think about what you want to do
think simple think about the need think
about the use case and go all the way
back to the granular experience of the
user and from there you can build to
amazing things so we had a mission we
had the vision we brought the right
people which was a hairy and audacious
goal and then we spent a tremendous
amount of time thinking about the
product and how granular it is but
that's not enough because we need to
hone it we can need to continue honing
it all the time to the point that we
understand the users really well and we
continue evolving it at all the time and
don't forget to use a lot of data I'm
sure that you're doing it but now that
you're in school but in order to make
better product you need to keep
iterating on them all the time start
simple and then iterate and iterate
listen to users listen to what they say
and just don't be afraid to launch
product very quickly not everything that
we launched or I launched in my career
worked a lot of things didn't work don't
be afraid just go out and the best way
to testing is with people test small
don't test big don't go don't wait for a
long time wait for many many months and
years to build the perfect things you
are going to be too late because if it's
an amazing thing someone would have
launched it before you right and if it's
not so great you just wasted a lot of
time create a proof of concept go simple
get it into the market and iterate very
very rapidly with users and it's okay a
lot of them will tell you that's not
working well you know one thing that I
really liked at the beginning with the
early adopting physicians and people are
asking me all the time why does
physician do that like how do they start
the whole thing right I'm sure that
someone will ask it here and the reason
that physicians at the beginning that
really engaged in what we were doing is
we got them really involved in the
process of giving us feedback and they
felt that they actually have a huge
impact on the product itself and the
doctors that helped us most were the
ones that were most vocal and trust me
you start getting these snarky emails
about how useless what we're doing is
and like this long four pages email that
like the whole emails back this is
terrible and this is wrong in fact when
I see these emails the first thing that
they do is pick up the phone and talk
with
person to make best friends with him why
because it just spent three hours
queuing my product it doesn't matter a
snarky the email his day care about my
product they're the best thing that can
ever happen to you they love it enough
to to just you know maybe use a future
curse words or whatever it is but it's
okay and consented to that because they
will give you feedback and there were
the best people for us but we didn't
have money to hire QA people they were
the best QA people and they got very
excited because we listened to them they
participated they felt it their own and
now the doctor community owns what we're
doing the lava the invite doctors invite
one another the best way for us to bring
more doctors on board is doctor inviting
one another why because it's their own
and we still do that so product matters
a lot
iterations model a lot simplicity
matters a lot if you think about these
things you're going to have an amazing
experience for people last but not least
tell me that I'm very passionate about
is positivity right so we have this
mission and vision we have a great group
of people that have a hairy audacious
goal we're focusing on products we're
iterating we're moving forward we need
to stay positive as I said at the very
beginning especially if you have a hairy
audacious goal and you have a very lofty
mission and vision you'll encounter
challenges along the way and you're
gonna have a great great people around
you that will help you encounter these
challenges but you need to stay positive
all the time almost to a fault right and
that's really something that is acquired
I mean like you can actually work on
this because there are some amazing
techniques that can help you stay
positive all the time so I had this like
huge opportunity to travel around the
world and volunteer in a bunch of places
and I like running and these two things
together brought me to an amazing
realization at one point in my career
that smiling which is an extremely easy
thing to do has amazing powers so
traveling around the world and meeting a
lot of people for the first time and
many of them I couldn't speak the
language I didn't know the culture I
traveled in small in 70 countries and
when I volunteer in a place in
to communicate the people is not that
easy when you don't speak their language
but the one thing that instantaneously
creates connection among people is this
one it's universal it doesn't matter
where you are right it really connects
with people really well and that was a
big aha moment for me but it is not
prompted from me they wish to go and try
to learn about smiling deeper and
research smiling was because I
discovered kind of randomly when I when
I run and I used to I still run every
day and I would to run longer distances
and I discovered that you know when you
run a long distance run and after you
know an hour an hour and a half and kind
of becoming a little bit more tired when
I smile that kind of felt kind of a
sensation of elevation which comes back
you know I thought it was maybe random
or like I'm making it up or whatever it
is and I kind of tried to it came to me
naturally and then I try to kind of
induce it and ice it still felt better
and I said okay I'm just gonna go and
start doing research to see if it's just
something weird that I'm experiencing or
is there something in it and and I spent
a great amount of time really doing
research into smiling it's amazing I'm
not gonna repeat the entire thing right
now there's a whole TED talk that I gave
about that and I wrote a book about it
and but I think that what I discovered
in my own life my own life is that it's
very it's possible for each and every
one of you to actually build positivity
into your life but just being conscious
of it right leave the moment right and
yes you have this hair you know - this
goal that you want to accomplish which
can easily put you in a position easily
put you in a position that you're going
to be frustrated all the time right
because if you climb Everest and you
keep thinking about the summit all the
time you are going to be frustrated most
of the time because you're not on the
summit yet right so if you keep thinking
about the challenges and why you are not
where you really want to be you're gonna
spend your life being frustrated on the
other hand you're a lot of great things
that happened to us every single day
that are a lot of fun and if you live in
the moment and that's the biggest
learning point that I can tell you about
my research on smiling is that if you
live the moment and you surround
yourself by things that remind you that
life is great
but you live in a place that has amazing
weather now spring outside
the flowers are unbelievably amazing
look at them I mean they're gorgeous
it's sunny here right every single day
you're surrounded by amazing people
you're doing but something that you're
really passionate about every single day
right so life is awesome even when it's
challenging and if you pause to remind
yourself that every single day and even
better if you surround yourself with
people that help remind you that every
single day the journey becomes so much
better and positivity is a set of mind
is something that you can just decide to
become positive and being aware of it in
the moment is something that will bring
you back to it and I use anchors right I
call it my dandelion leash right there
are certain things in my environment
that I kind of tag them as smile
inducing I just decided have a list that
I decided that whenever I see one of
these things if you just remind me to
smile and I make sure that these are
things that are you know encounter in my
environment every now and then and their
conduct you know they're reminders for
me like oh I see this like always Pam
but some people that make me smile
another thing so this is my little
technique but you can do it however you
want to do it but deciding to the remain
positive is extremely important when
you're conquering these kind of
challenges so let me start again and
then I'll pass it back to you mission
and vision having the right people
around you making sure that it's a big
thing that you want to conquer that will
make a big impact on people's lives
focus on the product focus on the detail
keep it simple but do so create
something great create something amazing
create something that inspires you think
about what the details that make it
amazing and last but definitely not
least probably the most important thing
stay positive thank you
questions no question when you look back
on your personal journey and that could
be your childhood that could be your
journey after after leaving home you
save to those pivotal moments that
really kind of emphasize that really put
you on your path to understanding what
was important even why yeah it was
people at volunteering I think more than
anything else right so when I traveled
around the world and I tried to stay off
the beaten track right so I tried to go
to places that are more developing
countries where there's more help needed
and in spending time with people that
are not as fortunate as us right and
seeing I mean we live in a bubble
obviously right so we you know what we
think is difficult and challenging and
all these things there obviously you
know they're very luxurious challenges
right a lot of people in this world live
in conditions that are you know
extremely basic conditions at best and
we spend the time trying to help these
people and connect with them but I level
with them right when I travel in these
places when I volunteer I always use
local transportation I always try to go
and spend time with the people where
they are and when you start seeing where
they are versus where we are I think
it's it's it's it just for me it adds a
lot of positivity because it makes me
feel very fortunate right for what we
have here and it makes me want to help
even more so I think that this is
basically like working with people and
helping them I think creates the
realization but also create a lot of
great gratification or gratification
when you can help we can provide value
yes
yeah I think we are very focused on
looking forward right I mean I think
that you know my philosophy is wear the
yellow jersey right so being available
do the new things push the envelope
right try to do the new things and then
you have obviously you are followers if
you go in the right direction I mean you
know we we started with our you know
philosophy and what we're doing right
now with virtual care you know about
five years ago you know before it was
very cool to do digital health and all
these kind of things and now it's became
very cool you know but we started way
before that right and now we have a lot
of people are trying to do what we are
doing which is great
I mean it's validation to what we're
doing but I don't spend a ton of time
looking at what other people are doing
I'm really focused on the on the user
I'm really focused about on the
experience I really focus about what
problems we are trying to solve and
really figure out how to provide most
value in this environment I think that
you know the interesting thing about the
stage of where we are the company right
now is that we're trying to think about
rather than think about other players in
the industry as competition trying to
think about them as potential partners
and how can we empower them with what we
have to do what they are doing better
because even if you can't solve all the
use cases we have a lot of underlying
assets that we can provide to partners
to help them do what they're doing
better so they can focus on use cases
that we're not focusing and make the
entire ecosystem better when everyone
benefits from it right so this is the
kind of thing that we're thinking about
right now yeah because we give the
corporate side and think too much about
the process and what we try to do it as
we need
and it's very difficult today try to do
see we can in fact in your case what you
did before at the beginning we unique at
all right so a lot of things we're
trying to do the same thing so cancer
so maybe the difference in your kid was
all the rest so you keep the grecian
that gives it the energy to keep the
Crito
and you were positive so maybe in our
own experience we try to focus to motion
the product to make it unique and maybe
you don't have the right people and even
in fact you are not sure about your
vision your care only about the protein
and that is happening very much today
yeah I think I'd like that you know the
essence is really about what is the
problem that was trying to solve Frank
at the end of the day is there a big
need out there and ket do we have the
right kind of skills and the right kind
of experience and expertise to go and
tackle it and provide value at a very
large scale and bring the right team I
think up like when you think about the
people that surround you really think
about how to hire the best person in the
world for the job that you have at hand
really seriously I mean challenge
yourself to think about if I could
choose any person in the world to do
this particular job how can I find the
best person in the world one of the main
reasons that we are still on University
Avenue here in Palo Alto and you haven't
moved anywhere else is because we are
doing a lot of work at hansard and the
reason is that even in our engineering
level or in products that are in design
or in data you know we're looking for
the best smartest people even in
entry-level right because they will
tackle challenges that are pretty a
pretty immense right so bringing the
right talent right the smartest people
the best people in the world to tackle
each and every one of the challenges in
the entry level which we are hiring from
Stanford and other great institutions or
just in debt now in the executive level
as we are ramping up the company we want
to bring these executives to to come and
join us so now we're thinking about we
just hired a senior executive from a
fortune 500 company that just left a
very cushy job to kind of come and work
with us at the startup because he's the
best person in the world to do that
right so think about it when you
surround yourself by people how do
choose the best person in the world for
every particular job you're hiring for
let's go in the back yes you found it be
well which is quite successful
organization here at Stanford and that
experience itself sounds very
entrepreneurial itself as well so I'm
wondering you could compare your
experience in the bewell and experience
and healthcare from an entrepreneurial
perspective how are they similar or
different how does how did the
experience from pwhile contribute to
your own inner eclipse yeah I mean look
I mean entrepreneurs always look for
opportunities to make an impact try it
today
you know real interpreters always look
for broken stuff right like work I
always look for what's not exactly the
way it should be and how can I go and
build something right I always want to
build something I always want to fix
things right so if you are at Stanford
right now and you're surrounded by you
know amazing people but there are also a
bunch of challenges around it is nothing
better than starting to hone your skills
of tackling challenges by just going and
doing it particularly an environment a
great environment like that when you
have unbelievable access to talent for
free right like you can just put like I
put a multidisciplinary group of
graduate students and faculty that if I
had to hire them in the real world it
would cost me a tremendous amount of
money but when I was at Stanford it was
like just like a study group we just got
together a couple of times a week we
spent hours together on whiteboards
thinking about stop doing research with
the University gave us a lot of like
opportunities to do research right
primary secondary right spend a lot of
time with them together and learn a
tremendous amount in the process yeah we
make it up made it applicable so it's
not just academic research but we
actually try to apply to an actual a
real-world problem but you can actually
bring some of these most amazing people
argue an experiment right experiment
rapidly with things that are good ideas
and see how they work in an environment
it was a great environment like like
Stanford and with visionary people like
John etchemendy the Provost at Stanford
and several other people here they will
give you the amazing opportunity to do
certain things that are very big if you
are committed to it if you want to take
the challenge on yourself so I really I
think that you should try it every
single day just find the right people
find the right challenges going practice
going and and train for what the world
is waiting for
afterwards yes James could you share
with us well as the biggest challenge
you've had to being an entrepreneur yeah
absolutely I think the the most
important challenge as an entrepreneur
is what I said you know a couple of
sentences ago is really finding the most
amazing person for every position in the
company but it's the number one most
important thing right so I think that it
and it's very easy to compromise right
it's very easy to say this is good
enough right like all you need to run
very fast and you have like deliverables
and you know you don't have enough
resources and you need to just run run
run and accomplish really big things so
when people are coming in cycle you know
this is this is a great person or she's
a great person and and think that's very
skillful but you know maybe cultural fit
not that great right so but we really
need someone to do this job because if
we're not gonna do this job we're not
gonna meet the deadline if not gonna
meet a deadline
oh my god who knows what will happen
right and I think this is short-term
thinking I made these mistakes in the
past right I made these mistakes in the
past you take great people but maybe not
great culture of it right or not exactly
right for the job that you're bringing
they're not the best person in the world
to do the thing that you need to do and
it's not just about skills it's also
about fit right and I one piece of
advice to all of you don't compromise on
that ever it doesn't matter what the
next deadline is it doesn't matter what
you're trying to accomplish people are
the most important thing right so from a
challenge perspective thinking to
yourself how do i pace myself in what I
want to build so I can bring the best
people in the world for every stage of
the company we didn't need to hire a
fortune 500 executive into the company
in the first six months of the company
it would be a waste of everyone's time
we need to do it now because we need to
scale up right so who's the right best
person in the world for now right and
don't compromise never compromise yes so
we never from engineers like you did
failure is important in not being afraid
of failure
is important brother says you're under
company for which failure is actually
got that acceptable right so what
happens a bit like whatever the doctor
gives bad advice specifically and how do
you deal with this idea that people are
putting a lot of trust in you but you
don't really control the information at
all
yes so I've helped up we have only two
molds success and learning and I think
it's a very important set of mine right
at the end of the day I mean we are
human we are fallible
we'll make mistakes that's always
happens right and if you want to create
an environment of innovation you want to
create an environment where people take
calculated risks calculated risks right
you need to create an environment by
which failing doesn't exist learning
does if you could do it very quickly if
you can do it with a limited amount of
resources you know I don't encourage you
know learning and you know spending a
tremendous amount of research but the
quick iteration with limited amount of
resources that creates learning it's
actually the best way to get to where
you want to go it's a very iterative
process so I don't look at learning as
failure right as long as you don't
repeat mistakes again and again and
again right so it can make new mistakes
there as long as you make new mistakes
every day it's fine it's all good now
the question that you're asking about
you know doctors and the fact how they
manage patients and you know you know we
really want to believe that medicine is
a hundred percent science right and I
think that you know we will give
medicine a huge you know kudos for
making a huge progress in the past
decade in century decades in century for
making more progress to making it more
science-based
right but medicine as a combination of
some science in some art right so there
are opinions of people of how to deal
with things we're trying to bring as
much data as we can and put opinions of
many doctors rather than one doctor like
we did with rate rx when doctors are
rating medications and providing data to
to make choices but you know different
doctors have different opinions right
when you look at rate directs and how
doctors are rating medications you see
that there is a difference there right
so they have an opinion right so it's
not about right or wrong it's about
trying to bring enough data right
from multiple sources to help doctors
make better decisions in context I think
the fact that we are building digital
channels and everything that's done on
health talk is recorded everything that
is done on health tab creates this huge
repository that is not only
transactional right and a lot of
businesses there's you know in
marketplaces the transaction just
finishes the time the transaction
finishes so it reconciles and then it
just moves in the head or helped up that
knowledge is captured right in and we're
learning by you know they you know when
we get from people information and we
get more data the health tab itself
learns a lot and the learning that we
bring together actually we can provide
doctors to make better decisions right
when it can when they provide
information to patients so we are
empowering doctors to make their own
decisions we are making it easy for them
to access data to access information to
access other doctors knowledge right at
any given point in time and provide
better answers and better information to
people as they're doing ah this side yes
could you go a little bit deeper in the
console of the similar the caveman and
they're now they people a little bit
deeper what why do you find it so
similar the denominator would be oh sure
I mean I think the simplicity of it was
like people had a trusted entity like a
person a healer that they went to that
had the knowledge and they found it very
desirable to come and ask questions
right and they went to the healer or
they go to the doctor today health care
has actually two components to it one of
them is the knowledge itself and a lot
of it at a data part is care so health
care has two parts with Health and Care
the knowledge and the caring I think of
what's important for us to emphasize and
when I made the analogy is that
sometimes we go to doctors to get their
knowledge and sometimes we go to them to
get the support and the caring right so
we need to remember that because we are
all scientists we are really really
excited about the data we're really
excited about information about learning
and about the science behind it but we
need to remember that in healthcare it's
also about caring it's also about
compassion right so accessing not just
knowledge in an article but access a
physician that actually
cares about you it actually answers the
question that you asked rather than the
generic question is really really
valuable you have a conversation with a
human being rather than interacting with
an article Wright was very very valuable
there as well so there's more than just
like the basic experience the basic
experience unpacked for us a combination
of the knowledge and the caring yes you
and your team members I'm curious about
how you went about recruiting doctors to
provide service on your platform whether
or not you went after people that and
really push the vision of what you're
trying to do or be more focused on the
financial benefit or otherwise for the
doctor now you communicated that yeah
it's a great question I think that we
very very strongly emphasize at the
beginning the several fury initial years
of health tap that there was no
financial reward at all right so we
really were looking for the physicians
right that are mission driven and want
to actually make a difference in the
world and help people so there was no
financial reward whatsoever not money no
t-shirts no Amazon gift cards right
there is no money exchange whatever we
didn't charge money either and we didn't
put ads on the service either to
monetize it right so we provided the
service for free but doctors provided
the knowledge for free and buildest like
amazing knowledge base that is available
all over the world today to everyone for
free
they Billy together 68,000 doctors
worked really hard to build this
unbelievable knowledge base but from the
very beginning we made them partners in
building it it wasn't ours it was theirs
you know when I started helped up I
actually you know flew around the
country to meet opinion leaders in
pediatrics and obstetrics with a set of
balsamic sketches right on an iPad to
show them what what is it that we're
thinking to do and what I really
promised them at that point is nothing
more than that come iterate with us we
will listen to you and I was surprised
by how many doctors told me that no
certain no software provider ever asked
him for their opinion but they brought
their scent consultant to show them work
which buttons to push on the interface
like lots of consultants but never asked
him what they really want what they
really need and what we did from the
very beginning is iterated with them
together and listen to them we made sure
that when they gave us advice we
actually acted on the end of us and
until this very day we sent service to
doctors every other week and we have
thousands of doctors that are involved
in every generation of health care that
we launched to the world so with their
real participants in the process of
creating this unbelievable global assets
that we have created that help them
you